because if someone puts up a poster in a
town square that says guitar lessons
available
like you don't get people in the town go
I don't want to play the guitar I wanna
play the piano you piece
that sign wasn't for you it was for
somebody else but again that's what the
world is like people take everything
personally I think the world revolves
around them right particularly on
Twitter I don't know I'm not tweeting
anymore I'm just tweeting okay I don't
know who's following me I've got 12
million followers I don't know who's
following me they can be following me
without me knowing right choose to read
my Tweet and then take that personally
that's like going into a Town Square
seeing a big notice board and there's a
notice guitar lessons and you go but I
don't [ __ ] want guitar lessons
thank you
what's this uh there's a number here
right all that right
are you giving me tall lessons yeah I
don't [ __ ] want any
fine it's not for you then just walk
away don't worry about it the world got
to see James Corden as a fat [ __ ]
also in the movie Cats but
no one saw that
um and the reviews oh shocking I saw one
that said this is the worst thing to
happen to cats since dogs right
but Dame Judy Dench defended the film
saying it was the role she was born to
play because she I can't do this next
joke
because she loves nothing better than
plunking herself down on the carpet
lifting her leg and licking her
[Applause]
all right furball verbal she's old
school
um